hs français je suis sûr que tout le
monde me comprends et je suis sûr qu'en
particulier tout ce qui est jeune qu'on
prend quand il le dit le vieux bonhomme
le bleu français que je suis il n'aurait
pas beaucoup servi l'europe s'ils
avaient été des apatrides et qu'ils
avaient pensé écrit en quelques
espéranto ouvre la puck intégré qui a
jamais cru que le général de gaulle est
appelé à la barre devrait se contenter
d'inaugurer les chrysanthèmes je dirais
à ce sujet puisque j'ai le plaisir de
vous voir et de vous parler
il est tout à fait vrai que depuis
toujours et aujourd'hui je me fais un
effet de la france une certaine idée ce
pouvoir à une apparence un quarteron de
généraux en retraite ce qui est à
redouter
mais quoi ce n'est pas le vide politique
c'est plutôt le trop-plein
vous savez la politique de la france se
fait pas à la corbeille
c'est pas la gauche la france c'est pas
la droite la france hélas hélas hélas la
france c'est tout à la fois c'est tous
les français bien entendu on peut sauter
sur sa chaise comme un cabri en disant
l'europe l'europe l'europe si vous
croyez comme il faut le croire que la
grande querelle sur la terre c'est la
querelle de l'homme
reconnaissez que c'est cette querelle là
que la france soutient en algérie être
que décalé à totti aurait pu ou liberté
publique fondamentale je les ai vus
il ya une seconde attendit jamais
beaucoup roulé ou qu'à 65 cents je
prends une carrière de dictateur vous
faisait bien son en brière
mon cher et vieux pays nous voilà donc
encore une fois ensemble devant une
lourde épreuve
ce soir il n'ya de la lumière comme on
peut regretter la douceur des lampes à
huile à cinq combats or une seule patrie
d'un instant talo de nous précipiter au
goût paris arrive à y arriver
l'appareil est bien la maîtresse de
maison la ménagère elle veut avoir un
aspirateur devant un frigidaire
françaises français aidez moi aiment
avoir une machine à laver et même si
c'est possible qu'on ait une tour vous
ai compris
en même temps je crois que son mari son
amant bôshi to pas que les gars on met
les pieds sur la table et que les fines
entre pas la nuit et l'effet de mon
inexpérience est vrai aussi pour la
france il faut le progrès il faut pas la
pagaille que ce sera 10 968 l'avenir
n'appartient pas aux hommes et je ne le
prédit pas je vais vous répondre tout de
suite
je ne vais pas mal mais rassurez vous un
jour je ne manquerai pas de mourir la
vie et la simple et tranquille peuvent
évoquer une paisible demeure non pas un
grand peuple en marche
[Musique]
vive la république
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]